u.s president joe biden announcing that
the u.s military has
achieved its goals in afghanistan and
according to him
america's longest war is ending he said
that the military mission in afghanistan
will conclude on august the 31st
but he also did say that u.s support for
the afghan people
will endure he went on to say
that afghan leaders themselves will have
to come
together and countries in the region
should step up efforts to bring about a
political solution
for the country on the taliban he was
questioned about the taliban by the
reporters
and he did say that the taliban is at
its strongest militarily since 2001
but the taliban takeover of the country
he believes is not
inevitable in the wake of this u.s troop
withdrawal let's bring in our white
house correspondent kimberly halcott
joining us from washington dc so the
president is very much
defending his withdrawal plans in
afghanistan kimberly
you did a nice job of summing up the
speech and i think i want to highlight
on a couple of the points that he made
because there was some news in the
speech you noted the
august 31st withdrawal date that is
a moving up of what he announced in
april when he said in fact all of the
u.s soldiers would be out by september
11th the 20th anniversary
of the september 11th attacks in uh
not only washington but also new york
city so that is notable he did not give
an explanation
for moving up that date only that that
is now the new date
uh some of what the president had to say
is not much different than what he said
in april he certainly underscored once
again why he was making the decision
he was and outlining the enormous cost
that
american soldiers have paid in trying to
ensure that there was not another an
attack
on the u.s homeland not only the
casualties that number
in the thousands but also the wounded
and those whose scars may be
mental in terms of the ptsd that they're
suffering that is
even an untold number thanking those
service members for their service but i
think some of the biggest
news moments of the speech came in the
question and answer session
that the president held afterwards
because
on the one hand he talked about how his
secretary of state anthony blinken
will be continuing diplomatic efforts to
see that there is a negotiated
peace effort in the region but at the
same time saying that one of the parties
the taliban that is a part of that
effort the u.s president was asked
whether or not he trusted them and he
was very emphatic when he said
no he does not so it almost appears as
if he's undermined that process
from the podium the other big headline
in all of that
is that the u.s president has been very
clear that despite
dire predictions from security experts
members of congress former members of
the administration
passed there have been these predictions
that the taliban
will in light of the gains that have
been made take
over potentially kabul other major
cities the u.s president emphatic in
saying that he does not believe that
will happen
that this is because of the training
that has been provided by the united
states
the ongoing support that will be
provided and also the enormous amount of
money and investment that the united
states has made
so the u.s president commander in chief
striking an optimistic tone
even as there are grave concerns about
the future of
afghanistan kimberly hawking thank you
so much for
that a wrap-up from washington d.c let's
bring in once again david sydney who's a
former deputy assistant secretary of
defense for afghanistan pakistan
and central asia thanks so much for
sticking around uh just to pick up on
something important that kimberly was
mentioning mentioning a moment ago
why do you think the president has now
said that the military mission
will conclude on august 31st as opposed
to september 11th which was the original
date well the administration has gotten
a lot of criticism
for the decision the process from the
time and tying
the end of the military mission to
september 11th was seen as
really a blatant political ploy with no
base
reality so making that shift uh to
august 31st
is designed to get rid of the damage
that the administration caused
so they shot themselves in the foot and
now they're they're binding up the wound
uh on that side uh but otherwise uh it's
your correspondence said that
prison bride pretty much stuck to that
decision i didn't change anything
um did make a number of uh
semi promises for afghans who may have
worked with the us government
but he also ducked a lot of questions uh
he also sounded confused and bumbling at
times
and he also said that the taliban is at
its strongest
militarily since 2001
but then he believes that the taliban
takeover of the country is not
inevitable i mean what do you think he's
basing that on
he's basing it on hope uh he doesn't
want the taliban to take over so he's
adjusting reality trying to adjust
reality to what he hopes
and then there is in fact
a lot of analytical views inside and
outside the u.s government
that the taliban could take over and the
biggest reason is this abandonment
of the afghanistan by the united states
there's very little in what the
president just said now to give hope to
the afghan hope to the afghan people
hooked to the afghan military
our hope to the afghan government that
the united states will be able to stick
by the coming months of the year
how do you make sense of 20 years of
fighting
to according to the u.s take out the
taliban that's why they went into
afghanistan
and then watching the taliban gain more
and more ground
at the end how do you make sense of that
well of course the united states did not
go in
to afghanistan defeat the taliban as
president biden said the united states
went into afghanistan to get osama bin
laden right and to stop terrorism
us the united states never actually
declared war on the taliban the united
states never actually
designated the taliban as a terrorist
organization
that's why it's so interesting that
president biden was so emphatic that he
doesn't trust the taliban
while at the same time saying he trusts
the agreement that the taliban signed
with the former administration so again
there's a lot of confusion here
i want to make one very serious
correction uh
president biden said repeatedly that
afghanistan has never been unified
in its entire history that's not true
afghanistan has been a unified country
has been a country that's been in the
30s 40s 50s and 60s
before the cold war before the united
states
the soviet union started fighting over
afghanistan afghanistan
was a small quiet peaceful country so
the united states
states and the rest of the world have a
lot to do with what happened
but what president biden said about
afghanistan never being a unified
country
is just not true david sydney we'll
leave it there but we thank you very
much for joining us and giving us your
point of view
all right thank you